in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some streaming chefs
avoid performance heartburn will we
master the secret ingredient stay tuned
to find out
previously we covered the various ways
to profile and get visibility into the
start of time for a kubernetes pod which
is important since that's exactly where
the bacon live team was running into a
problem their startup performance was
behaving like a piece of dried out kale
because it's a food app it's a pun
anyhow let's get to profiling bacon live
had ported their code from compute
engine to container engine and as such
all of their containers initialized in
the parallel phase of the pod boot
process in fairness they did have a
single a NIC container that was doing
some sorry bald guy we can't tell you
about that work but we'll ignore that
for now applying the profiling process
from before we ended up getting the
following data three of the containers
were taking a significant amount of time
to boot up most impacted were the public
and admin endpoints which was
problematic since those were crucial for
the usage of their system looking at
that code for the public endpoint the
reason for this problem became crystal
clear the initialization code for the
public container was doing a quick call
over to the stats container to make sure
it was up and running before proceeding
forward the problem is that the URL
fetch command is a blocking call the
result is that the public endpoints and
NIC code was waiting around for the
stats container to finish initializing
before moving forward obviously this was
not ideal since it looked like we had a
dependency on the stats container our
first attempt to solve this involved
moving that container into the anit
phase so the parallel containers didn't
have to get caught in this weird race
condition and could execute properly but
when we time things again we realized
our mistake the init phase got two to
four seconds longer which resulted the
entire system startup being worse off in
general since all the rest of the
containers were delayed as well this was
obviously wrong direction and made the
whole boot time slower at this point the
bacon live team decided to go back
through and make some small changes to
their code the stats module was there to
help do timings of startup related tasks
but since they now had visibility into
those things outside of their code
thanks to be profiling harness we've set
up for them they were happy to remove
the dependencies for these and
this allowed them to get the same timing
information as before and move this
deaths container back to the parallel
phase without the dependencies the
result was about two seconds improvement
and availability time for their public
endpoints the bacon live team realized a
critical pattern for start-up
performance in kubernetes avoid parallel
and NIT dependencies where possible
thankfully we were able to profile it
get visibility of the problem and fix it
before anybody noticed if you'd like to
learn more tips and tricks for making
your cloud as fast as possible make sure
to check out the rest of the cloud
performance Atlas content because when
it comes to performance every
millisecond counts